et ce soir pour le point sportif du à
lundi jacques et grégory canal et
bonsoir oui j'ai volé votre place ce
soir vous avez pris celle de michael et
demi d'euros et on va faire le point
avec vous sur les championnats du monde
de cyclisme première étape qui avait
lieu ce week end à saint quentin en
yvelines et il faut retenir wilfried un
bilan mitigé pour les pistards français
trois petites médailles obtenues à
l'argent en vitesse par équipes pour le
trio baugé vigier d'almeida médaille de
bronze en scratch pour adrien garrel
d'argent à thomas a lui remporté le
bronze dans la catégorie omnium est la
délégation française entendait pourtant
scorer sur cette première manche avec
notamment 1 mathilde grolleau jeunes
pousses tricolores elle malgré le
soutien de sa famille c'est une
quatrième place au sprint et seulement
8e place au keirin catégorie pour
laquelle elle avait obtenu un titre de
championne d'europe il ya forcément de
la déception dans la voix du directeur
technique national mathilde gros elle
veut retenir le positif écouter quelques
quelques regrets on était à domicile on
espérait
peut-être avoir des résultats des
meilleurs résultats on a tenté e
plusieurs de nos sportifs sont sortis
assez rapidement
dans les manches de qualification donc
quelques regrets plutôt prendre les
points positifs regarder toutes les
erreurs tactiques que j'ai fait pour
pouvoir aller mettre en oeuvre enfin
voilà justement de ne pas faire les
mêmes erreurs dans une semaine à toronto
donc pour l'instant je ferai un bilan
des deux semaines
enfin les deux bouts d'une petite
déception tout de même pour mathilde et
qui va devoir rebondir par la suite côté
organisation est ce que cette première
manche est un succès eh bien c'était la
première fois que l'enceinte
saint-quentinoise recevait l'événement
environ 3000 spectateurs sont venus
chaque jour sur ce vélodrome qui compte
pour à peine 5000 places qui n'a donc
pas été complètement rempli mais ça
reste satisfaisant à 25 nations étaient
représentées c'était donc une bonne
répétition en vue de ces jeux olympiques
2020 très 4 qui arrive pour le vélodrome
saint quentinois qui accueillera pour
rappel des épreuves le vélodrome a plu
aux athlètes présents écoutent à ce
propos cette pistarde italienne est
aussi la ministre des sports en
déplacement samedi au vélodrome
une belle répétition d'organiser des
coupes du monde et championnats du monde
chez nous en france dans cette
installation
la fédération va y faire aussi ses
larmes en tant qu'organisateurs et bien
sûr les territoires qui sont aussi
présentes
les élus qui peut voir aussi de quoi il
s'agit par ce que je peux prendre des
décisions en connaissance de cause c'est
toujours mieux et je ne l'imaginé pas
comme ça qu'il est vraiment très beau je
souhaite bonne chance au vélodrome pour
les jeux olympiques il accueillera ses
voeux que le che tourisme il reste
qu'elle se trouvait en europe est bloqué
in a high tone et olemps pas le
vélodrome de 50 en une qui devrait de
nouveau accueillir une épreuve de la
coupe du monde du de cyclisme sur piste
une manche de cette coupe du monde et ce
dès la saison prochaine
merci grégory on vous retrouve à 18h30
si vous nous suivez en direct pour le
7-8 sport le point complet sur ces
mondiaux de cyclisme et puis sur
l'actualité yvelinoise saint-quentinoise
en matière de sport merci